in pain now
[Applause]
thank you marshalls
this is a story of the most
uncomfortable two in a bit hours of my
life and the man who was responsible for
it but first let's go back to the start
all right it's 8 a.m on race day
time to get ready
so i have something of a race plan we're
going to start here we've got a nice
easy bit before we go into the first of
the two tunnels gonna take it nice and
easy up until here beans it through the
coomb down tunnel
and then take it nice and gentle the
other side this is like the only kind of
hilly bit really there's a bit of hills
at the top and then we're going to go
along the canal and that's when i kind
of open up the taps and this is if i'm
going to pick up pace anywhere it's
going to be here on the flat and it's a
lovely bit of running it just goes on
for a very long time um so
getting off the canal take it easy then
you get to green park and that's like
your last final sprint oh vaseline for
my nipples my dad's running a lot of
half marathons in his time and like the
one piece of advice he always gave me
was take vaseline put it on your nips
because you see so many people at the
ends of half marathons who are just
bleeding from the chafing so
don't let that happen to you kids this
is it's not glamorous but it's practical
all right so we are walking
to the start line we just got the bus in
i'm also joined by pixel girl
[Applause]
who uh i don't think i've mentioned yet
but is also running the road she didn't
want to be left out in all the fun uh so
she's been training as well
she didn't want to be left out on all
the fun
i won't lie
i'm feeling more than a bit nervous
about this
pixel and i had a week of self-isolation
on top of a short truncated holiday
about two weeks before the event
so um
we uh we we've definitely missed out on
some training we definitely feel like uh
we're not coming into this in peak
condition
so this is
it's gonna hurt
to briefly explain all this
paraphernalia obviously i had to film
the race this is how i filmed the first
video which is like a gopro on a
chestnut but on top of that making me
really look like an action man i've got
um a water vest because originally the
race said that they wouldn't be
providing water because
whereas now apparently they are so we've
got a litre of water in our backpacks
like a little platypus camelback type
thing um so now we just look like we
were just very over prepared like not
all the marathon runners had these we're
doing half distance
but yeah we're not gonna run out of
water anyway ah
and i think we may have a problem
i'm gonna have to wear this like a
teletubbie
because the camera's in the way of our
normal footage
yep no avoiding it
i look like a teletubby
full of tubby custard as well all right
last minute banana we've got to go in
the pen and like five minutes how are
you feeling about this
i feel like i haven't trained it
well we did slightly have our training
cut from under us by self-isolation
so give it a go
i need a haircut as well no you don't we
say this every week look how raggedly it
is it's not raggedly
what does raggley even mean pixel got
insisted that i show you how nice the
back of her hair looks which she did
herself didn't get any help
and it made her arms ache because it
took like three hours okay i think we've
gotta run 13 miles now i'll see you in
the pen
finish your banana first
way to ruin the edit at the end of the
day the reason i'm doing this is for the
cystic fibrosis trust we've raised a
huge amount of money and in that sense
it doesn't matter what time i get like i
would like
i'd be unhappy if i was more than like 2
15. i know that i'm not going to get a
pb because my my training and
preparation has just been
shot
but if i could get under if i get under
two hours i'd be very happy but like i
say that isn't the reason we're doing
this the reason we're doing the cf trust
and you people viewers have raised
nearly 4 000 pounds as of the time of
recording you're incredible and it's
gonna make a massive difference so now
in return
watch me suffer we will go in 15 seconds
time good luck everyone three
two
one
one kilometer down
first of the two tunnels just coming up
that's got room to stick to the plan
and keep it slow
well done well done what's this a new
character approaches
this is my mate dan he's the reason i'm
doing this half marathon go watch this
video where you find out why i see a
simon coming
hey
danvi if cystic fibrosis doesn't kill
you i'm going to kill you
you do it join the tunnel go man go
well done
thank you
had simon run past me about i know
kilometer from the start
now i've got to walk into town see if i
can catch him there he's going the long
route i'm going the short route but i'm
walking and he's running so we'll see
who gets there first
thank you marshalls
here we go
hear that music
it's playing from
speakers along the walls but one
instrument speaker
i now need to do is slow down
so far
so good
[Music]
unfortunately that was a bit was easy
look at that view
thank you marshalls
chance for breathing
that's what we
that was all we just ran over
not quite a third of the way there
had a little bit of one of these
syrupy
jelly things
which has definitely helped
pick me up
nearly at the canal ah what a lovely day
for going for a nice
leisurely stroll around bath
oh what could be better than this
thank you marshall
you might recognize this from
the fundraising video
this canal is about
third to a half
of once you're off the canal
you know there's not too much further to
go
unfortunately for me
i knew this bloody started it
okay nearly halfway
i need to be careful not to
over extend in pace
so i always do
but at the moment i'm on track for
i think a respectable time
the danger is
if i think i'm going fine
and then trying to speed up
i'll crumble before the finish line so
i've got to be disciplined
i am getting tired
but
right up ahead
so if you can see that eminem town
eight miles
he's doing the marathon he's just a lot
faster than me
and fitter probably more attractive i
didn't get a good look at his face they
might be a later wave with a half
[Music]
this next section of the half marathon
is brought to you by
ah
thank you marshalls
okay so now
there's a section of the route
it looks like about end
i am running up the urethra
i found him again
i got him again
i'm in so much pain
come on man
come on man you've got this you can
still donate at the just giving pace i
will see you in the finish line
[Applause]
okay that's come out the tip of the
urethra oh it's painful this bit
i can see the 11 mile time of the head
two miles to go 2.1
ah
so just kidding please do
make this worth it
i don't wanna attempt fade
i'm feeling a little bit back
third wind whatever it is now uh
hard enough walking this i don't mind
running it
[Music]
thank you marshall
painful oh but you're almost there
you're doing so well ah
oh that's the hill
and right at this point just before the
end of the race my camera encountered a
technical problem
it ran out of battery so over to me just
after the finish line
my camera died
hey
it died
five minutes before the end
and i empathize that was
so painful
i collapsed at the end
obviously i lied and i just my legs gave
way i just couldn't anymore
i just looked for my pace analysis
actually and like
it was really good
up until maybe
three quarters of the way through
so like
i had it mentally
and then my fitness just wasn't there
like i needed to have trained i'd like
for a few more weeks
to actually sustain that pace i think if
i had i would have done sub two hours
um
i just
i think going self isolation losing
basically two weeks of training
really chop the legs out under this one
like i'm still
pretty pretty pleased
but it's like you can see
when the wheels came off the bus a bit
at the end of the day
finished
raised a lot of money for a really
important cause
and i got to see danby during it
you
you just had to be born different
yeah well done
[Music]
[Laughter]
i've done three half marathon races now
and i can say with absolute certainty
that this was the most painful the most
uncomfortable of them all i do think it
was the best running like technically
that i've actually done i was really
consistent with pace up until the point
as i said at the end that my fitness
kind of just fell apart i needed really
maybe two or three weeks i think to
prepare but i still think it's a
respectable time and i also
think that's not really the point the
point is that you wonderful people who
watch these videos have donated now over
4 000 pounds for the cystic fibrosis
trust which is a phenomenal amount of
money it's going to make a real real
difference to people like dan and if
you've watched this video and you've
enjoyed my suffering in the shard and
freud esque way it's still not too late
to donate to the fundraiser it's down
there in the description simon clark cf
on justgiving and all donations really
do make a difference this is a really
important cause and i'm i'm so happy
that people have rallied around this to
date and hopefully you will too there's
no funny punch line to this video
because i had to edit it the day of the
race and so i am absolutely knackered so
if you want to watch some stuff there's
some stuff here but thank you for
watching thank you very much for
donating
write your own punchline put it in the
comments bye